back lot of stuff to look
at really I just had one extra thing I
wanted to do on this tonight
yeah this one may or may not work we
will
say to its credit it is finding faster
stuff but I don't know about this longer
term I do know that this one is
good one is very
good
going just answering a couple things and
then I have just a few things I want to
try
today a few things to improve
progress removing J removing J is
actually
working that's working pretty darn
this is without
G very solid
here I'm just going to guess on some
things and we're going to see
don't if you're getting ads it's because
twitch is running ads
I don't think I've been to a Burger King
or a McDonald's in 20
my diet has been pretty damn good
lately I mean it depends if you
consider you know lean and red meat good
because there's a decent amount of that
but overall has been pretty
good actually the hardest thing with how
with how I'm eating is I got to gain 10
pounds back I have no idea how the hell
I gain 10 pounds
back as all my gym equipment's getting
here
tomorrow it's going to be real
water weight no I mean gain I have to
gain 10 pounds of of muscle
back
32 five so 5 over two is I mean
I think that's actually not going to be
bad then
five gem yeah nice home
Gem and actually I'm getting a upir b
there's a lot of equipment I got to get
soon but for now for where I am here
ml6 where's this with the cables so one
of these but it comes with
cables yeah this
thing pretty freaking solid this is like
everything you'll
need for a home gem set
up this is for here where I don't have a
ton of space I already have a setup in
California where I go and then my
family's place in Maryland well that's
going to be another
desert Texas
desert I think Texas was a desert
now linear gets
0.25 power on log and then what about
loget we don't really have many logits
or we won't once we're done with this
but
um logit
normal and .5 is what we
did thinking of starting a YouTube
channel I mean you could I don't know if
I would necessarily bother
I would generally think it's way more
productive to put time into
uh actually like learning and building
stuff
I don't know if I were you I would just
focus on getting
uh getting some good Engineering in
building some good
stuff much better use the time
s okay so I think box zero should be
free by now
four yeah so this there was an internet
DC or whatever
scale okay
so next thing I want to
work I mean I can show you what I did
when I was way younger like the thing is
it didn't really do that
much like I don't know if this really
did very much where is
website huh oh there it
is yeah I don't know why it didn't show
up
before but like I documented some stuff
like
this you know I put some stuff like this
just an old Weebly site
fine I remember I did this is this was
like a little 3-day project I made like
a little CLI
wrapper used it for freaking anime
pictures his high school
cringe I think I was 16 in this
photo I mean you can't really see as
much now cuz I lost a bunch of weight
with pneumonia but I'm still I'm up 40
lb Now versus that picture at about the
same
height I actually have the same stupid
haircut now is there because I just
haven't been out to get my haircut in
tuned yeah I used a Mac all through high
school until uh huh I mean the thing is
I majorly compensated for
it I majorly compensated for it so this
is what I did you know right as soon as
I graduated before College I built this
thing this like crazy monstrosity
SLI water
cooled and then I had this was my laptop
I used in the first couple years of
college yeah don't water cool it's not
worth
it I wouldn't even suggest an all in one
necessarily for the CPU I just go in
there cooler
actually they probably like
here what would I get on like a
reasonable
here it would be like this
with you say 50 70
[Music]
TI well it depends what you're using it
for
the CPU is freaking nice but if you
for the CPU is freaking nice but if you wanted to save some You' do
this okay I wouldn't do the a the all in
the liquid to do air
cool and probably
64 and a 2
tbte something like that
so take off you know 500ish 600ish if
you build it yourself just over two
grand probably for something
decent like decent
enough
yeah it's cheaper to build it yourself
you can go ahead and build stuff
yourself I I've built like six or seven
systems at this point um it's no longer
worth my time right but I do think it's
a good thing for you know people to have
built their own
machines but like literally think about
it right
so if we take this to its logical
conclusion if I'm going to order 40
machines if I were to build 40 machines
right let's say that I let's say I build
uh two machines a day right I can
probably do three machines a day and you
have to install a and everything as well
and set them up so let's say I build
three machines a day that's more
reasonable that's still going to take me
like 2 weeks right so two weeks of work
it's not worth my
this
seven protein maximize score cool for
Map
size
perfect so hopefully this is
good we should have some sweeps going
here
now check
[Music]
ablations got pop for
breakout your sweep
and we've got a
Rd X is better than twitch on
mobile it's funny because twitch is
supposed to be the optimized streaming
platform kind of a mess up
it's kind of weird that this
is seven or eight
score the
heck Puffer breakout Auto
scale did I run the wrong thing
breakout slowly loses
time that's
funny something's very weird here if
this is stuck at
six I guess that's probably like random
or
something we'll give it a little bit
because
but that's
particular yeah there we go so score
this is
good this one makes
yeah I'm a bit confused with this
one I'm a bit
confused oh did I forget use e3b hang on
I think I might have done a
fine
these coefficient spreads are all
fine yeah I actually don't know what
this what's wrong with this
thing I guess I can try to uh to run it
meeting with a guy who invented a drill
with no moving
parts next week that's 10 times faster
than regular drill
what a drill with no moving
yeah I would assume so but I assume that
there's a cheat in there
right it has to move to go through
material what's your recent breakthrough
it's been a while since I tuned in which
one we've got
multiple um I think we're going to be
able to replace generalized Advantage
estimation in po and I think we also
have state-of-the-art hyper parameter
tuning oh plasma of
course why didn't I think of that solv
all
problems but yeah two major
breakthroughs and I came up with a third
algorithm idea today
repl yeah I know
right and by the way here's the coolest
part we replaced J gamma and lamb go
poof no more hyper parameters added back
to replace them two of the top three
most fiddly hyper parameters poof gone
never to be seen again in
R pretty cool right
I think that the first Major General
algorithmic advancement since 2017 would
be worth
uh that would be worth something I think
that would definitely be worth taking a
look at puffer
for are you going to publish this I'll
probably write a blog post I'm sick of
conferences they're such a waste of
time cuz here's the funny thing I don't
think that this is going to be like a
once in a blue moon occurrence where
like I never come up with more crazy
discoveries I think this is now going to
be like the standard is that these
things happen quickly cuz puffer's just
at the point to support it
I would love to know what's wrong with
this sweep
though side by side so I think the only
thing I want to get done tonight is
to compare these side by
side very exciting yeah thank you I've
been hard at work on this stuff you know
it's it's a lot of work
but it's going to be something
cool like I said we are going to make
reinforcement learning stable and
consistent this year that is puffer's
goal you know that is these are the
level of results that I need to have to
justify myself doing this versus
anything else
right it's like if I'm really really
powering the field then I think I can
justify to myself you know spending the
last couple years of my 20s working on
this I like solo building stuff so it's
pretty
cool what do you see after well I solve
RL like I fix RL and I don't know
hopefully I make enough money in the
process of doing this um even though
it's all open source right hopefully I
still make enough money in the process
of doing this that I'll just be set and
I can you know start a lab in whatever
other to like power whatever other areas
of science and research I feel
like I don't think I'm really the type
to work in in like a big company
environment so I probably will just keep
floating around like solving various
things in different research areas
hard tech next could be hard tech
next I'd probably have to go back and
learn some math I mean we'll see we'll
see how quickly AI takes off right if AI
solves everything in the next few years
then there won't be a need but if it
takes longer then yeah I could go back I
could go learn some math would only take
me a few months I would imagine to get
to be at least passively decent
like if I really wanted to learn not
like theoretical proof-based math not
math department math but if I wanted to
get like passively decent enough at
engineering math and like engineering
stats to be able to do some stuff I
think I could do that in a few
months all the money you're going to
make yeah well right now though we like
we don't really charge very much much
it's like a 10 it's
starting 10 20K a month stuff like that
for support contracts but you know if
puffer is the place to come for RL
eventually we're going to get a $10
million contract from somebody who like
wants us to optimize the power grid or
something right if we're really the
place to go for RL so there's still
plenty of money like plenty of prospects
for puffer to become very very
profitable I don't hate money money is
good it's just not the primary objective
of puffer
going around RLC everyone says Tabby
losta doesn't
work that's because they all write [ __ ]
code like literally open any RL
researchers code it
sucks that's why it doesn't work it's
because they don't know how to build
stuff we have tabul rasa and it works
instantly
tabul rasa means Blank Slate so it means
learning from
scratch it's like these people go around
saying oh tabular R is dead this didn't
work that didn't work you never even
tried you never even tried and the proof
of that is the pace at which I'm making
breakthroughs right like I'm really not
a genius
yes like if you guys had actually tried
I wouldn't be able to be making these
breakthroughs so
quickly like you do you see all the dumb
[ __ ] I do on
stream I'm not like some crazy math Guru
with like you know Arcane formula that
have never been seen before by anyone in
the field no I'm just like huh this is a
six deep nested four Loop that would be
better it weren't nested six deep I'm
going to fix that hund did Le do and it
works continuous control feels
fundamentally harder we are actually
testing whether it is fundamentally
harder right now and we have continuous
control
Integrations that will be expanded going
forward honestly I think continuous
control is pretty easy it's going to be
pretty easy when we get the engineering
right games are way harder like solving
DOTA from scratch is way harder than
controlling a
humanoid efficiency gains in alos nope
efficiency gains in simulation and uh
not wasting time on like I don't know
running python for
Loops some efficiency gains in the
algorithms maybe but I think we can
solve a lot just as is
I mean it's like when you actually look
at the code like you say oh man that
like robotics that looks really hard
right that's like and then you open
their code and it's the worst thing
you've ever seen and you're like oh oh
you guys aren't doing anything there's
no way that you have any idea what
you're doing if this is your code looks
like because I have no idea what this
code does at all either I don't think
anybody has any idea so you just have
this 10,000 lines of garbage that you
don't know what it does that everything
else is built on top of and you think
that you don't just have tons and tons
of errors in there that are preventing
you from doing
code just stop writing bad code it's
that
easy and the crazy thing is when I say
stop writing bad code
like I'm not even asking you to use like
I'm not asking you to use any Advanced
Techniques you don't need to go learn
metaprogramming you don't go need to
like read these 10 books of
objectoriented design or functional Pro
you literally need to write [ __ ] for
loops and if statements not in Python
that take the data and return the data
that you need without nesting five
functions deep for no
reason that like call each other in a
circle or something it's not hard
I mean literally like I will open the
code bases right and I'll be like all
right so this inherits from this which
inherits from this which inherits from
this and this function calls this
function which is a wrapper for this
function which calls the super classes
function here which calls this other
super classes function which does
nothing grand total of nothing for all
of that repeatedly
give a crap about your code yeah
literally that's it that's all you got
to do and you
win that's honestly the only way that I
got better and like it took me a long
time because I'm incredibly incredibly
stubborn and uh I basically refused to
take advice from anybody but uh just
caring about my code got me there
eventually sp3
oh sp3 is not good my friend sp3 is no
good I don't recommend s sp3 to anyone
if you want to use something that's like
simple the same performance as SP sp3
and really easy you go for clean RL
clean RL is amazing the only problem is
it's not that fast cuz it relies on like
gyms vectorization and ends and stuff so
I made clean RL fast that's what I do in
clean puff RL but for like you know
looking and using algorithms compared to
sp3 oh clean RL all day cost is amazing
he does great
work honestly I don't I don't think I
there's a single person in RL I can give
a higher endorsement of than
going to run this on the
local just to see if I broke uh
something with po or if it's just the
run it's actually so funny to me as well
cuz I thought clean RL was bad code when
I first looked at it but that's cuz I'm
an idiot I was an idiot and like Fang
people will look at clean RL and they
don't get it either and it's because
they're
bad and it's so easy to understand as
well it's like look this is the sales
pitch
right here is PO for Atari okay it
doesn't import any other clean RL things
it's just using torch gymnasium that's
it and it doesn't have 10 files it
doesn't have thousands of lines
everything you need about PO is in these
286 lines of code and that includes all
this AR parsing and this m stuff and the
agent definition and then the actual
code for PO is just here's your storage
here's your collection here's your
training that's it it's less than 200
lines then there's some logging and
that's it so this is everything that you
need I generally advise people to finish
high
school if you're good enough that like
that a legit startup like a really good
startup wants you at a high school right
like want you when you finish high
school then you go for that fine I'm
cool with that you can do that for a
year if it doesn't work out you can go
to undergrad right but uh I definitely
advise finishing High
School you haven't though is the thing
because you don't realize that it's not
a work requirement it's a Time
requirement all
right you haven't finished it until you
actually get your
degree or your diploma
if your high school will give you your
diploma then sure that's a different
story but if you have to drop out of it
then now that's a dumb
idea the other thing that I think is
underappreciated which I I definitely
didn't appreciate at the time is just
how much of like the social context and
stuff for how [ __ ] gets done in the real
world that you are missing when you like
16 um like that takes till your mid 20s
to kick
in
so yeah that's the other
thing you'll see you're just like you're
just missing I guarantee you if you're
like your typical computer nerd type
who's like even if you're good at math
and programming and stuff you're just
missing a [ __ ] ton of context for like
how decisions are made in the real world
like how stuff happens you're just
you're missing like you're seriously
seriously gimped on a lot of stuff that
you're trying to
do that doesn't mean that you have to go
down the normal route for everything but
I think it's a good idea to at least
finish high school and then see if you
can do it right see if you can go get
picked up by a good startup or
something yeah and the thing is it's not
your fault either you should be
literally if you're doing it correctly
you should be right like I literally one
of the hardest things for me was writing
college essays why they ask you to write
about like they ask you to write
personal essays it's like [ __ ]
I've been working 100 plus hours a week
for the last four years how the hell am
I going to have had any time for
personal development I know how to do
some math and I know how to write some
code and I know how to like you know do
my coursework and do research that's
what I know how to do
time nah dude there there's no way I
guarantee you there's just no
look if you think you're good enough
right go through the process of trying
to get like you know trying to get a
cool startup to get you to work on some
stuff
Tyler didn't you just didn't you just
have to go like didn't you just have to
go set up yet
recently sure you can train him in
physics
oh yeah your mental health is going to
be [ __ ] in high
yeah now your mental health is just
going to suck in high school that's just
that's just what it's going to be go
lift some
waves did that help you at all
yeah I think it was generally a good
idea to have like some understanding of
basic
physics that was probably one of my
favorite
courses it was actually well taught it
wasn't just taught to the AP
curriculum my high school didn't teach
stuff just to the AP curriculum I mean
they teach you enough stuff from that
that you can go take the test but they
did some more it was a good high
school so what happened between these
two that's totally different
too
slow well it depends on what else you're
doing with the other hours in your day
right okay yeah so there's totally
something screwy
right I mean the AP exam should be
pretty free if you're
smart okay I will say I don't know I
only end up reminiscing when I talk to
people that are still in that phase of
their life right but um the one thing
that I did that I thought was pretty
damn genuinely
impressive uh was after I got into
Stamford I wanted to max out my transfer
credits right so I wouldn't have to take
a whole bunch of stuff uh in undergrad
so what did I do is I had like three
months to study all right while I was
finishing my courses but you know I
could I didn't have to worry about
getting perfect scores on everything I
could drop a few points here there so uh
I took three years worth of Spanish and
two years worth of Chinese on my own in
like three months and I got fives on the
AP Spanish and the AP Chinese
test I was the only non-chinese person
taking the uh the Chinese test as
well the AP Chinese one is
not but I to be fair I think they cut
you a little bit of a break if they can
tell you're obviously not Chinese cuz
they're like okay
yeah okay we get
it I mean literally it's like you walk
into the room right and it's like you
know it's like 30 Chinese guys and this
one white
guy it's like what the hell you're
taking the AP in your own damn language
this
pong hang on wait this looks like pong
doesn't
yeah something's definitely wrong
because at least the initial run should
have
gotten a much higher
score environment SL
score oh no this does get
6.7
o5 oh this is very tight
bound
okay how would I suggest you go start
about go find some startups and cold
email the like go cold email the CTO of
startups go like cold DML founder or CTO
or CEO
I mean you can attach one if you want
but you can also just like try to start
conversations with people that lead to
stuff
right it's kind of better if you like
start like an interesting conversation
than if you just jump straight to like
here's my resume
I'd probably go look for stuff with like
probably between like 10 and 100 people
size I think Tyler's trying to get
himself a cheap r
that
restream
listen to stream while working out I
have not bench pressed in two
months I get my rack
tomorrow I am looking forward to finally
being able to do some proper lifts again
got a lift I get cables as
well so
uh this is going to be uh we'll start
the rebuild and we're going to see I
think I'm going to take stuff a little
easier at first on the at least on the
size of the weight the like as far as
not going super heavy I had a 265 bench
before
um uh before pneumonia I had a I think
it's pretty solid 265 bench and can run
a marathon that was in pretty solid
done so much math sometimes basic math
look
complicated that's where these days
improvements
are there's some very simple map in
Puffer
I there can't be there can't really be
complex math and puffer because I don't
know
any yes I did multivariate Cal in high
school and then I proceeded to do
several more math classes that's that
when I say I don't know any math the
standard is very different right yes I
probably
took what six or seven different like
math heavy classes in undergrad and you
know college plus grad school and stuff
that still counts as knowing no math
see figure fractal partial
deprecation fractal partial diff
equations for cell similarity
what are we working
on so uh I would like there to be an
automatic mode for hyper pram sweeps
where you don't have to set scale
parameters for all of your different
hypers so I'm working on
moment they're
better that was the best I knew back
then stop trying to understand math and
you'll be much
funny and as
uh PhD and
AI try not to work with shitty code
bases and you'll be much
happier memorizing I didn't memorize
anything
barely SL math is really interesting
yeah I mean we have some algorithms here
right we've got a we got some gaussian
processed stuff in the hyperparameter
tuner the new algorithm we came up with
uses some stuff as
well it's um like variational RL so
what's it you throw a gaussian negative
like Gauss negative log
likelihood
on uh predicted value
function or predicted mean and variance
or value function
and then what was the other one I came
up with I think the other one was
simpler I was looking at doing expected
Improvement but it made it didn't make
sense for
this that should come like
G and
Optics Gan
processes I know anyone who loves Gan
processes they pain in they ass
how do you get unstuck when
stuck I've seen you have been working on
your
own well what was what's there to get
stuck
on I remember when I was newer when I
was a newer program I would get stuck on
stuff for days and weeks that very very
rarely happens anymore
I kind of just know how to get how to do
stuff now you
know it's like you're going to not have
a bug if you don't make a giant ass mess
of your code and if you do have a bug
it's going to be easier to
fix I generally have a pretty sharp
intuition as well of um you know what
areas things are likely to work what
things are likely to be promising what
things
aren't I think highle intuitions I have
on like where to steer RL like what what
are the levers that I have to really
lean on to make this stuff go forward I
think that intuition has been very very
much
sharpened so I don't usually waste
massive amounts of time on like wrong
projects oh years of it
right I mean it may it mostly just comes
about it comes from giving a [ __ ] about
a specific area for over a decade right
and then like really thinking about like
what it is that drives It Forward right
so you know I don't read very many
papers at all these days uh because I
know most of them are wrong but when I
was starting out right I kind of like I
went through all the different areas of
my field I kind of like tried to develop
the Insight of like okay which of these
areas are going somewhere which aren't
which of these problems make sense which
ones don't but I was really thinking not
just about like my one thing I was
thinking about how do we push the field
forward and that's still how I look at a
lot of
stuff why didn't decision Transformer
take off it it's
offline you attracted a bunch of
people did
I uh what's the what are we at here it
only shows three on Twitch right now for
me
I don't have a view count on YouTube so
I assume nobody's
there well that's i x doesn't it's not
141 concurrent uh X just says it's total
view count so it's the total number of
views since the stream started so that
number that number can go up to like a
thousand or whatever
no I don't have 141 concurrent ever I
don't know how many I have on X
ever but with YouTube and twitch
together sometimes it gets to like
10 yeah that's just that's people
getting served the uh the stream
scrolling by it or like tapping it on
their sidebar checking it really quick
usually it's it's not that many
concurrent in general through your work
well yeah I mean something though that
I've I've put effort into right the
whole neural MMO was a community project
and I had competitions around it um and
then you know I've really put a lot of
effort into promoting the stuff I do on
with puffer on stream and on X and I've
put a lot of effort into making stuff
simple and easy to use I've put a lot of
effort into user support I've put a lot
of effort into like supporting academic
projects on this
programming well the thing is it's long
form it's very long form content right
this is kind of just me doing my work
throughout the day so yeah if you watch
you know specific things you're going to
see like you're going to see like stuff
that I do but it's a lot of stuff to
watch and frankly I don't really watch a
ton of programming content outside of my
work um it's kind of like I just think
about my work a ton and then when I'm
I'm done I'm
done how many puff people are following
puffero are people using it contributing
oh yeah we just hit a thousand people in
the Discord
today um and you know we have every day
we have people asking stuff in there you
know we have heck uh over half of 2.0
was written by contributors we're
merging in we just merged in another big
environment there's another giant
environment that's getting merged in
pretty soon as well there are a few
smaller ones that people have been
working on a lot of stuff defense got
hella views well I mean you know that
could have gotten a ton of views or
could have knock gotten a ton of views
right I've done lots and lots and lots
of different things over the years and a
few of them have got to blow up right I
put a lot of effort into that defense as
well that was a pretty good talk um I
put like no effort into my PhD thesis
like the actual manuscript I put no
effort into that thing but I put a lot
of effort into the talk right right if
IID flipped it around if I put all the
effort into the manuscript nobody was
going to see that
anyways C environments are
fun C environments are
fun so this thing still doesn't work
huh it's
weird see so
second I just want to see real quick
what's wrong with these
hypers traced me in the summer yeah I
mean I've been working on it since it's
been full time since
spring
um well pretty well full
time in the summer I was also training
to run an ultra so that took a [ __ ] ton
of
time but
uh yeah I pretty much was just doing
that and
working so batch size here is all over
the place batch size
here is the the
same learning rate is way more variable
here
O2 learning rate is way more
variable terms of working hours how long
do you think I should take to make my
app should be
taking well it's going to take you a
hell of a lot longer than it would take
me right I would suggest you pick
something that you can do in like 200
lines of actual C logic plus the boiler
plate hey
man how's it
going supposed to emerge an m to puffer
a while ago but got sidetracked what M
did you have I would uh hey we're always
looking for new
Ms okay so learning rate is too tightly
bound right now definitely know that
weird I'm pretty sure these were the
same weren't
they hang on something screw it with
that
hey man it's like you don't owe me
anything it's just if you want the code
review on stuff you know if you want the
RL input then you merge M it's how
Works hey
bet
welcome what the hell is wrong with this
so gamma
gamma's logic scaled
right if we set this thing to
Auto 0.25 was it
0.5 oh it is 0.5
okay
fine I have to mute
what stupid thing
why why Claude plays Pokemon what about
puffer plays Pokemon fix sweeps yeah
sweeps
work sweep work pretty well we're just
putting some tweaks on
stuff uh anthropic did a thing where
they made Claud play Pokemon and they
horribly underperform our 5 million
parameter model courtesy of that guy
and
bet and maybe a bit of my advising a lot
of and a lot of my
compute closer to 10 mil ask same
thing lot of my computer
yes you've been restricted on boxes
lately because we need uh I mean we're
running stuff now I would hope that you
have found some stuff lately but uh yeah
I think you're in a good
spot some of my runs are just unstable
is this my fault or is this your
fault genuine
question my fault at this point all
right good less work for
[ __ ] it we do
this when it comes your
fault then I'll complain again
solid hey I do screw stuff up
occasionally
we're just trying to get the sweeps to
be
um we're trying to get like a decent
default automatic scale on
them the new J the no G algorithm works
as
well and it's actually we've got a nice
new Dev brand for it I'm going to merge
everything to Dev as soon as I fix this
thing with sweeps and then we're pretty
much going to be ready to start running
some hardcore
experiments that' be cool
uh why is Peter only see my [ __ ]
tweets
I like occasionally I'm just feeling
stupid late at night and it's
Fair
glsl we have a couple shaders for the
environments you know
I mean we're not
fair but if he ever has a scandal he's
got the perfect term for it it's just
elongate
look us retards get stuff done
elongate look us retards get stuff done that's what I say it's like look if I'm
that's what I say it's like look if I'm
being stupid as hell half the time on
stream and I'm still making the progress
and what are you
you get back to building a w
site oh puffer's got a pretty good one
of
those speaking of which all this RL is
free and open source on
puff. Star the GitHub to help us out for
free really
helps Discord next as well
this is pretty fun this is just
JavaScript and uh well this is all just
CSS HTML and a little bit of
JavaScript and like we've got all these
nice environments you can click them and
like it loads the uh loads the wasm you
can watch him doing stuff
right very
nice that PS Gemini against another
Gemini reverse
GPD that's fine
I've been using Rock a fair bit just for
research lately and it's been pretty
here bad size is
fun
O2 okay so it's possibly just the
learning rate right
this totally could just be the learning
rate what's gamma look
like 9
six oh yeah that's a reasonable
sample so gamma and Lambda are going to
match
Now update
EPO te Horizon these can be like this is
fine
um cost
coefficient is this one
[Music]
to this is fine
hiring lying about video games
what oh the
account yeah I don't know what the hell
that was
do you think that he did the speed runs
but uh paid somebody to grind his uh to
grind his like his leveling in his
gear I don't
know that was funny though I don't know
what the [ __ ] that was about
didn't play any no he plays a lot of
games that guy plays a lot of
sleep apparently before the I think it
was before one of the launches or
whatever I think it was in his bio he
stayed up like all night playing Elden
with Grimes and then just went to his
rocket
hell that's probably
Fair pay with cursor
ah man I don't [ __ ]
cursor it's so
[ __ ] I wreck my [ __ ] nice code
bases all that
garbage you know like I do occasionally
use language models to try to generate
code Snippets for the fun of it and they
suck just write bad
code I literally have C or muted as a
keyword on
X not working hands on in every
company probably not uh not now that
they're set up
yeah you probably I mean the way a lot
of these things go right in engineering
is it takes a lot of time to get the
things set up and then it kind of runs
itself for the most part minus you know
some major
decisions lar to was an expert that was
the new one right was that poe2
I think that was po too that was weird
which LMS have you
used Claude GPT
rock look I better be better at writing
code than these things right I've spent
my whole life doing this
stuff I can tell you they write shitty
code yeah they write better code than a
lot of phds but that's a bar Sol low you
have to dig for it
yeah I mean I'll show you the stuff I I
use grock for it but like this is
literally I mean this
is it's like only a moderately helpful
at Best
Thing hang
on I mean this is the thread I use for
my G
stuff right it's like it's so verbose
cuz does all of its thinking it does all
of its damn thinking in the token space
here right so it literally has to write
everything out in order to think about
it so it's really really verbose I use
it to see if I've missed background
references so sometimes it catches those
it brings up a bunch of irrelevant stuff
a lot of the time it's kind of useful
sometimes at like hacking out and symol
substituting stuff it generally gets
derivations more or less
correct uh it poses really stupid ideas
that don't make sense in research terms
at
all but like
yeah I don't know I try to stay off of
politics with my stream and x and
everything because ultimately this is
all about the science but you know I
like full Tech Guy builds full Tech so
I'm not not going to comment on
political stuff but I do like full
Tech no
concept we don't know what everyone
else yeah I spent some time looking at V
trce I mean there's like pages and pages
and pages of this I mean this is like a
long with
red RL still new models aren't being
trained on new
tokens the models aren't being trained
on new tokens so much you have to do a
lot of filtering from what I understand
the internet is really
polluted with like just garbage llm
outputs at this point anything that's
like
202 was it three 2023 onward
it's kind of
garbage and I mean I think Gro they can
train it on X right but then you're
training on freaking X which is like I
don't know moderately better than
trading on Reddit
maybe didn't somebody train a model on
4chan I don't know which one I'd rather
this one or the fortunate
one there was one on Instagram oh that's
like pure brain
rot yeah that's going to be pure brain
rot join papayi all right
you train gpt2 on
1.6 well that's not going to do anything
because it's
gpt2 how the heck is this still
not getting reasonable samples
like here I very briefly had a state of
the art language model
I think this was
it this was the whole
uh code of
it
I forget how big this model was I
it I forget how big this model was I think it was pretty
think it was pretty
small it's like 60 mil or
something oh this poster is big I
years spend all day
coding love Ling having a solid model
code while I review and
plan oh no I very protective of my code
bases I don't like anything dropping
garbage in
one I've never been to a hackathon
either that one probably surprises
people
I mean it's like oh yeah you guys are
going to go all sit in a room for the
weekend and like you know code for 36
hours [ __ ] I call that a Tuesday
evening my early 20s yeah this just
called Tuesday
evening I'd like code for 14 hours chill
out for a couple hours down a hip flas
for whiskey and called a
night was not a balanced under R but uh
I got a hell of a lot of stuff
done I don't know why this is not
working so well
be got to be learning rate
right 8 O2 yeah these are all way too
low I thought I matched this one
reason scale
Auto oh this this is
fine maybe one of the other prams is off
so I can't
tell gamma
gamma generally looks fine to
fine
see oh we have quite a few folks on
Twitch at the moment
welcome we're currently diagnosing why
the
uh well I'm trying to make some changes
to this hyper pram sweep tuning
algorithm trying to figure out why
they're not playing so nice
these are
fun how did no J work go working on
matching the return oh I got it
working it uh it matches or outperforms
on
breakout so we have a real chance at
having that thing be a lasting
contribution
I'm actually just cleaning up the sweep
Cod a little bit now and then we have
like probably five to six thousand
experiments to
run I wish I had the new hardware
already but it's going to take some
months in order to get the uh the new
hardware I want to get 40 50 90
boxes the new facility will be done in
about a
month but it's it's going to take a
while to get those
cards
months well to get the new
hardware you can't just like it's hard
to fulfill the orders now first of all
they're not shipping enough 590s and
second of all there's there's a problem
with them where they're sometimes
catching on fire so I have to figure
that
out well we're getting a test box with
1590 and uh I'm going to want to order4
40 of
them but I'm not going to order them if
I'm not going to order them until I know
that that issue is resolved CU I'm not
paying for 40 boxes that are going to
melt oh yeah thanks for the reminder bet
yeah for folks watching if you're at all
interested in RL and where it's going
just take a second to Star the repo on
GitHub it really helps us when people
star uh puffer it's like the main thing
that we track and uh I mean this is the
type of growth that we need to like keep
pushing the project forward
so you know it's on puffer really
appreciate that thank
you I thought this one would be honestly
I figured this one would be pretty easy
to get working I don't know what's wrong
or off
here better GP a 800 is way worse you
kidding me
is there
uh perf chart
it 100 T flops I know somebody can go
find the T flops on this
cheaper I don't know actually 800s are
pretty cheap these days
nice we have Capac for 40
machines and uh I know I know where to
get them at a 5% volume discount as
well uh for the full
machines it'd be about 5,500 per
box with the top end CPU and everything
per box
electrician no we have it's it's set up
correctly it's a new facility that's
wired for
I would think it's still the learning
rate
here that's broken
when you're calculating node G
loss to delay samples until you collect
end
samples you delay longer than that
anyways even in
J so it's the sampling is the same as
before even in po you wait until you
collect like decent length trajectory
segments otherwise G doesn't have
anything to Discount
over that's standard across all of
online
RL oh there was a paper at Nerf some
guys said that they got it
working they got po or they got like RL
working
online without um without waiting
you can go find the paper if you want I
don't believe them
but maybe grock will find
it I want to finish this first
though
yeah 20 kilowatt
inverter why Dr
plug uh the capacity ours is 40 kilowatt
capacity I believe
it's a kilowatt per
box so it's at least a 40 kilowatt
capacity I think it's a bit higher maybe
it's
same there anything else that's like off
I don't think there is
nvidia's pretty damn good about like
taking the latest models and just
optimizing
them wait b200 is 21,000 tokens per
second
what the chips aren't that much faster
are
they these chips are not 20 times faster
than an h00
right oh no h yeah this is software
optimization
here
okay it's funny
hey
Spencer we're
chilling getting late but
uh we are still looking at we're trying
to figure out some sweep
stuff I got a nice clean Dev Branch I
have to merge it into depth
proper probably be for
tomorrow still have to figure out what's
wrong with these
sweeps sweeps are fine it's just like
specifically there's one tweak I want to
make it's not
working trying to think
why yeah for
protein and then we can really run this
thing properly
this one's stuck at 50 because of uh
it's breakout with a small batch size or
so learning right here these are all
like 05s and 0 25s right
let me actually you know what I'm going
to
do yeah I know what I'm going to do I'm
going to
[Music]
do I want to see which of these are way
off
all right
so current
ones Max random
sample goes from Min 70 mil to 140
mil that it
mil
B learning
rate
and
entropy gamma
Lambda oh update Epoch cannnot
sample that's not
good value functions fine
is
[Music]
fine okay that's also fine
only one of these that's 08 is going to
be total time steps the rest of these
are
fine yeah I think it was just stuck on
random noise
honestly yeah you can see there found
one
uh the update PX one's not
good does puffer hook into maoko yeah we
have majoko binds Kung set up uh Kung
did a bunch of stuff on Moko for
us we also have done Isaac Jim
recently we haven't gone crazy with
majoko or anything mind you like mjx but
we could
pretty much we're going to like the
expansion into continuous control is
going to be client based so like if we
get a couple of Robotics clients we'll
do more stuff in that
area cuz right now it's on the cards
like it's in the cards it's planned but
it's not planned like super urgent
compared to all the other like
fundamental core algorithm stuff we're
doing you
View top floor Mountain
View oh
Hotel did you check
new risen AI
right AMD is GPU drivers go look at
George Hop's stuff AMD is [ __ ] for
AI like even if they have the hardware
their software is so bad they could give
you the hardware for free and that would
to still be too expensive
isn't it WR nope it's
cursed don't do
I will
email Eric
John I think I got an email I got an
invite to for figure
HQ um I mean the robotics people are
cool but here's the thing I don't want
anyone to hire me right now I want
people to hire puffer
right so if you want me doing RL stuff
on you know whatever
application you hire a
puffer it's cheaper that way for you as
well and you get the backing of all our
crazy uh new open source methods as soon
as they're out
actually I've got a great guide to put
on a new robotic stuff as well
so what did I set this
to set this to 0. five before didn't
if you set this thing to one it becomes
like Gan process driven random
this bothers me this definitely bothers
me
what is the heck wait what the heck was
it that was even linear in the first
place cuz I didn't want it to be a power
of two right
maybe 0.5 is just
good for this
stuff I actually don't know if that's
even enough right one
done but I do want to at least have
something to run for
now so this is what I'm going to
0.5 two can be
[Music]
.5 log can be
this logic can be
total time steps is the only one you
actually have to be careful
okay we'll see how that goes that'll be
interesting enough
we have the maze
running and we got
uh the maze
go yeah
so we'll see if this improves at
all
um I am going to hop on the Discord for
a quick conversation with some of the
folks there and then I'm going to get
some
rest so yeah for the folks on
Twitch very close to having all the
experiments all set up and running for
all our our next science side efforts so
if you want to just follow that Dev
process or if you're looking to get
involved in some open- Source RL
buffer. start the repo join the Discord
follow on X lots of content on here as
well including a quick start for
beginners it's very nice resource some
other posts and there's more on the x
that you can't find anywhere else as
well other than that I'll be
back probably first in the
morning first thing in the morning
um a lot more stuff to do on this